Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab, the podcast. Okay,
so Robert, here's the question
that I've been puzzling over, uh,
for a long time. All right. Okay. What
is the fruitiest fruit that you know,
my fruitiest fruit is a
plum. Well, no, I mean that,
well that's yours and I'm not, I don't
want to take that away from you. No,
you shouldn't. But when you
ask most people that question,
they say apple or orange.
No, I mean it's true.
Scientists have figured out that when
you make a category in your mind,
you're not doing it based on like a
set list of traits. You're like you.
What you do is you call to mind the
prototypical example of that category and
then you measure this new thing
against it. And for fruits,
prototype is the gala. Apple. If you
ask me the red, shiny, waxy apple,
you say there's somebody who's decided
that an apple is the fruity fruit.
They've, they've done experiments,
we've done experiments.
You'd bananas out poll
apples for consumption.
Maybe that's not what makes a
fruitiest fruit of fruity fruit.
It's a more about like how well
it represents the category.
That's what it's about. Are we
talking about this though? Well,
because I'd been wanting to explore
this in story form forever. Forever.
But you never have a story so it's
like a, you never find a story,
but I got one now. You did what? It's
not about fruit though. What is it about?
It's about this.
What is the, what are you talking
about? Let me explain. Hey.
Okay, so we met this Guy Andrew Morantz.
I work at the New Yorker as an editor and
I write stuff occasionally wandered in
here one day by mistake I think.
Super interesting guy, great reporter.
And he ended up talking
with us about this story.
He was reporting for the
New Yorker, but hip hop,
there are all kinds of rappers who are
trying to sing and how hip hop might be
changing because as we all know,
this was a genre of music that began
really specific time and place. Bronx,
seventies black and Latino kids.
But it's since expanded so much.
The DS, inevitable questions pop
up, you know, to really simplify it.
The more white people come to the
party, the more you kind of start going,
okay, at what point is it?
It's clearly a, it can clearly,
it's clearly okay if everyone in the room
is black and it's okay if everyone is
black except for one guy. You
know, if Rick Rubin's at the party,
but it's still, you know,
black people at the tunnel in
1989 or whatever, it's still okay,
but at what point, okay, we have
fits 50% white if it's 75% white,
if all the people who own
the record labels are white,
if a majority of the popular rappers
are white, like at what point,
and that's just the racial thing.
Then there's also that sonically,
the way it sounds,
there's the way the production is kind
of merged with other forms of music.
So then all of a sudden you're at a point
where you get the sense that there is
somehow inherently that there's
something being replaced or taken over.
You start to have this dilemma,
which is, you know,
who owns the music now?
And the dilemma is obviously heightened
by the fact everyone knew this was
coming like it.
There's never been a form of American
popular music as far as I know that wasn't
invented by black people and corrupted
by white people and Andrew in his piece
and in this story a focuses on a guy
who sits right at the heart of that
dilemma. One of the most
influential Djs in hip hop today,
Peter Rosenberg is his name.
Yeah. Yeah. So tell me,
tell me how you came to him.
I mean the first thing was
the most important hip hop
radio station in the world
listening to hot 97 because I like rap
and I want to know what is popular.
And I was listening and I heard this
guy who they kept calling Rosenberg
and I was like, is that Rosenberg? Is
that like Whoopi Goldberg Rosenberg?
Like what does that mean? And then
I looked him up and I was like, no,
it's just a guy named Peter Rosenberg.
One, two, one two, one two, one, two.
I mean listen, doing NPR is already
pretty soft. You know what I'm saying?
He actually works just
down the block from us.
This is going to hurt your credit and
some you know, positively. So He's a guy.
I'm born in 1979 he grew up in, I
grew up in Chevy Chase, Maryland.
The C h. Yes it is. Peter says when
he was about nine, his brother,
my brother's name is Nick Rosenberg,
his brother started staying
up late and making tape,
DJ, DJ red alert Marley Marl.
He would start taping
those guys on the radio
boy,
1987 98 and here in New York they were
the only two people playing hip hop and
it was late at night
and at the time I didn't consider
myself a music person. I was only eight,
but I really was like, oh,
music's okay, but I'm really,
I just obsessed with sports and then
at some point I was like, oh no, no,
I love this.
It was punk. It was rebellious. It
was interesting. It was just cool.
You know now too, to be honest, it's
almost cliched when people say that, like,
who would ever guess you'd
be into hip hop? I'm like,
I don't know I would because I know a
million white kids who are into hip hop.
At that time though it was not common.
It was very much something that was a
badge of honor for both of us that we
really, really loved it. And I was
extra cool cause I was super young.
I remember one day,
here's a great thing I
traded Javan my poison tape.
I had poisons album on tape.
Every rose has a store, an album.
I traded that poison tape
for his Bismarck key thing.
I was like this is the best trade ever.
It was business going off
like it's a classic album.
And then, and then at some
point my dad went out,
he was coming home from work one
day and he said he stopped at,
nobody beats the Wiz.
He asked the guy behind the counter what
like the good rap albums where and the
kid actually gave him a pretty good
recommendation and he bought me a tape
called girls. I got him
locked by Super Lover C and
Cason override.
Oh am I going to make a
jump sit through my beat.
On a one minute father you have,
I know he told me you're
stupid until you entertain.
Of course the new [inaudible] plus a
super in rocky point without doing the
chains.
So my knowledge base was
always very high, very early.
I had some friends in elementary school
and we would talk about rap a little bit
but quickly I exceeded them
and then I got to high school and I
really took seriously being the rap guy.
When I heard the passion in public
enemy like that resonated with me.
Like I say, NWA scared me,
made me interested. I just thought
this is crazy. I was like, Yo,
these guys are killing people.
Like this is really happening.
I was really happening. Are you
going to the movies in song form?
I was going to the movies but
to me I didn't know the lines.
Chemistry.
Okay. So Peter goes off to college,
mid nineties did college radio,
hip hop show and then as he gets out
decides he wants to do this for real.
He secretly, you know,
wanted to be a hip hop DJ but people
were not taking him seriously. You know,
white kid from the suburbs didn't compute.
He couldn't get on what was
then called urban radio.
So I ended up doing a year on the Howard
stern station and he was doing like
talk radio, you know, HFS, which I
was part time, whatever kind of radio.
So he kept calling hot 97 and the program
director then was a white guy from
Utah. I gave him my schpeel. I was like,
I'm super passionate about hip hop.
I'm super honest.
I don't think there's ever been someone
who looks like me and is from my
background who has his honest
and loud voices. Me. I,
I really think I'll be something
different. And he basically said,
I don't doubt you, but no,
what are you talking about?
I mean they had token white
people on various shows,
but it was either your
super white, like Lisa g,
she was on the morning
show for a little while.
I remember that she was super white
and that was kind of the joke.
Or you are Bobby Konders
who does the Sunday night radio reggae
show who you would never know if his wife
busted me. Feminine love of kindness,
Java, the whole [inaudible], Kingston,
Jamaica Duffel flex because he just talks
like he's Jamaican and he only plays
to make music. He only hangs
out with your making. People
would be one of those two things where
you denied your whiteness or you just
were like, I'm going to, I'm
going to be the butt of the joke.
White bosses have often been like,
you're really talented, but I don't know.
When people really like you like we don't,
they talk to me the way we're talking
right now and think if I'm able to relate
to you this way, why would our
audience relate to you? If I say yes,
then why would my audience
say yes with me? Because,
because they assume their audience
is so different than them,
which might've been true for a while
and then 2007 Ebro Darden took over Ebro
Darden in the building. What's up man?
How you doing sir? I'm doing great man.
This is him on air. Ebro, half
black, half Jewish guy from Oakland
and he got it. Did hip hop had changed?
It's no longer so small and simple and
provincial that we can go on pretending
this is only a black and Latino thing.
So when Peter came to the station
and gave him the pitch, Hey I'm PMD,
which was my old name back then, cause
I'm P P for Peter and MD from Maryland.
You can call me PMD and Ebro
was like, no, you're Rosenberg.
Ebro gave me my parents
name. I'm more or less,
he was like the the hook
is that, that's your name.
Hot 97 Peter Rosenberg and summer
jam 2007 there's a video on,
on youtube of a, it's
called Eddie [inaudible].
Peter Rosenberg does summer jam 2007
and it was my first day on the job.
Summer Jam is the biggest event of the
year at hot 97 it's this big show at
giant stadium. All the top
acts I showed up there.
And so my first day was just
walking in a giant stadium,
parking my car by myself,
getting the backstage pass and being given
a mic flag that says hot 97 the place
I've always wanted to work and being told,
go up to all the famous artists who
are here and just getting into it.
Got It. Hat run.
And if you go back and watch that video
and see how much of an ass I make of
myself, I say to t I think I go,
is this your first summer jam for CIA?
Have you done a summer down before?
And he looks at whoever he's with
and they both start laughing.
I'm asking, have you done many summer
jams? Today's your first day on the job.
My first day on the job you pack it
sail and I cannot believe in retrospect.
I survived to this day for the sounds
in Rosenberg show with Kay Fox on hot 97
not only survived,
he became the host of two shows on hot
97 a late night underground show and also
the big weekday morning show and
Rosenberg's brand is all about realness.
So the realness,
his segment in the morning is called
the realness is late night show,
Sunday night to Monday morning. Wait,
it's called real late with Peter
Rosenberg. It's all real, real, real.
It's going to be real. Really
Real. Keeping it real. Is it real?
Because that's the, that's the central
question. Can I be a real hip hop guy
even though I'm Peter Rosenberg from
suburban Maryland? I think you're,
I think you're raising
an interesting point.
Most outsiders rarely become insiders.
The Peter says the key to understanding
him is that he's kind of both.
Like on the one hand he is this
suburban white kid from Maryland.
He doesn't pretend to be anything
but, but on the other hand,
I mean a big part of Rosenberg's job is
to go to shows and blogs and get tapes
from people and find the new thing.
So he has a stable of like
20 or 30 underground artists
who are making tapes and
you know, trying to pass around beats
and what's more in salary than that.
Plus he is like a purist.
I've always liked there's a
certain pure form of hip hop.
And because you know in the kind of rap
nerd community they talk about certain
things that are like lyrics and listening
for the metaphors and the
intricacies of the music.
They talk about boom bap beats,
you'll get in the trade up.
That'll be big sounding. Drum wise.
It's boom bap like of kicks
it off yet original raps.
It's just a feeling of sound
of energy. This is Ali,
Ali Shaheed Muhammad, a
tribe called [inaudible].
We called him up because he is the DJ
and producer for a tribe called quest and
for Peter tribe they're the
prototype. I was obsessed with them.
They were, they are like
that shiny red apple.
They defined the category and in fact
I guess up until my wedding weekend,
best weekend of his life he says,
or I guess now it would be his
second best was when he was,
I was 14 you went to a tribe show. It was
everything I ever dreamed a hip
hop concert experience would be.
He says he spent the whole time at the
front of the stage waving this hat around
that said dog's d a w g S.
Cause one of the lead rappers is named
fife dog and I held up my dog's hat so
much at the concert that eventually fife
the five the five dog acknowledged me
the same way I would do now if I was
hosting and someone kept doing it.
He just gave me the hand like I got
it. You can put the hat down on that.
This was a weird moment for hip hop,
not just for Peter but
for hip hop in general,
like the early nineties this was a
moment when you had stations like hot 97
converting to all hip hop
formats, playing, you know, NWA,
public enemy tribe called quest groups,
you know that were suddenly attracting
loads of white suburban fans.
Yet if you listen to their lyrics,
nope, everybody for bottom line,
some of them at least
they were about stuff.
Those fans could have never experienced
struggle, depression, lack of
opportunities in the ghettos.
The fact that you have young
black teenagers who are
living in a society where
they're told that they will never amount
to anything and that their lives have
no value, no worth.
That to me becomes the,
the angsty and the
frustration and the rage,
which is the embodiment
of the music. Music.
I wanted to be a part of this of
black culture. Like I felt, I, I,
I've always been very interested in
loving things that required defense.
And Hip hop is definitely
that from the beginning.
It was initially shunned by black radio
because it was thought being decent.
Then you had the whole Tipper Gore
thing. I love things like that.
I don't know why.
And I think I do always see hip hop in
that sort of light in the way that it
needs defense. Can we talk about,
um, your, your frack is with, um,
Nikki Minaj? Of course.
That's my paragraph two. If,
God forbid I drop dead tomorrow,
it's Peter Rosenberg is on
holiday seven involve law.
The next paragraph in 2012,
Nicki Minaj,
um, is this rapper from
Queens, hugely talented rapper.
She, she's not the one on
American idol, is she? Oh, okay.
Now I have a face for
the name. [inaudible]
and she kind of blew everyone away on
this Kanya song called monster. You know,
she was with all these big rappers
and Jay z was on the song and she blew
everyone out of the water.
Those things each year,
the number start blocking
called t cause that's what
I thought. She was really good.
I thought she was a
natural and a beautiful,
like I thought she was a
total package. In fact,
the year before it all happened,
2011 I pulled her aside at
summer jam and I said, Hey,
I think you could be the greatest
female artist of all time,
the greatest female rap
artists of all time.
And I just want you to know that in
thinking that I'm going to hold you to a
high standard. So I probably will say
things about you. You said all of that.
Yeah, in a really quick moment
too. It was really brief.
She probably would even
remember it, but it happened.
We'd remember that if
someone said that, I said,
I think you could be the greatest. She
had all this underground credit. Right?
And, and then how did she
spend that credit? Well,
she started making poppier and poppier
records culminating in the following
song, which if you are me,
you've not been able to get out
of your head for a week. And
she made this song called
starships, let's go to the beach,
let's go get away. Starships
is a blatant pop song.
Lowest common denominators. I didn't,
I didn't like the song you listened to
that song and you cannot tell that it's
not a song by Katie Perry or
pink or it could be anyone
[inaudible]
so all of a sudden who is
the underground cred cop?
SciFest sounds in Rosenberg show,
but Peter Rosenberg and I know for a
second several mornings for his segment
called the realness. He would get on
there and play. I play a clip of starship,
check out this hip hop.
Oh
that's hardcore hip hop.
That would this song be considered
another hardcore hip hop song?
No, stop it.
That's not fair. That's not
fair. Maybe she's just, you know,
there is a real question being
asked at the center of this,
which is what is this music?
Where are the boundaries are and
also is this where hip hop is going?
Is it just let me cash in and just
follow the trends of what white music is
doing? It would be too strong to
call it like you felt betrayed as a,
as a music fan. Yeah. It felt like,
come on we I it just in the moment it
felt like you're, you're a hip hop star.
Why would you, why would you do
this? This is a, and this is not for us.
When core hip hop artists make pop songs,
it upsets me because it's,
it can be a moment that
blurs and messes up hip hop.
To be frank, this song right here,
starship is literally one of the most
sellout songs in hip hop history.
Just to put that comment in a little
tiny bit more context for just a second.
Now we mentioned of
course the history, right?
That so many forms of popular music had
been invented by black people opted by
white people, Jazz, blues,
Rock. We all know the store. No.
According to Frannie Kelly,
one of the hosts of a podcast
called microphone check,
which is a hip hop podcast kind of
NPR music according to her 2013,
was the first year that no black
artists had a number one song.
And since 1958 since they
started the hot 100 charts,
this is the first year where no black
artists have made it to number one.
Now this may be a blip, may not be,
but what's clear is that
there is a new force in town,
a style of music called
e. D m BDM is, is uh,
a meaningless acronym that stands for
electronic dance music. And it's like,
you know, more like speech
than a bap
[inaudible].
It's sort of an amalgam of Synthy
Dancy, techno, euro poppy stuff.
And it has taken over.
What happened with EDM was
just so glaring and fast.
And then to see that sort of start to
creep into hip hop was scary for people
because according to Frantic
Kelly would scary. Is it?
EDM is a style of music that's meant to
work on any dance floor with any crowd.
So in a way it's like a music
without history on purpose.
A lot of the criticism of like
EDM is that it is all about money.
It is the corporatization of
genre with a long history.
So in some ways I think the root of the
protest is don't sell our stuff to the
highest better.
So a little context. So anyhow,
after one of the most sellout
songs in hip hop history,
listen to it. After Peter Trash
talks, Nicki Minaj to star ships,
we arrive at that year's summer jam 2012
and that year Nikki Minaj was going to
be one of the big headliners plan was
for her to perform on the main stage
inside giant stadium.
But outside the stadium in the parking
lot earlier in the day there was the
festival stage,
which is where the underground backpack
kids hang out and that's Rosenberg's
zone. So he's introducing
the acts on that stage.
Now hold on, before I get to
the real hip hop of the day,
cause I see the real hip hop heads
sprinkled in here. I see him. I said,
in trying to hype up this crowd,
I know there's some chicks here
waiting to single star ships later.
I'm not talking to y'all
right now. That bull crap.
I know it goes Ooh. And she a
little bit like there's a cheer.
Nothing crazy though. Just irregular
cheer. It's not like I didn't,
a bomb was dropped.
I forgot that
not only was the festival
stage live streaming,
but it was live streaming on
her website and her core fans,
her barbs as they're known,
are 13 year old girls.
And when they see Peter
say that they go wild
and they go out on the Internet
saying, Oh, who is this Rosenberg guy?
What is his deal? And he says,
within minutes it got back to Nicki and
her people before she went on stage,
before she went on stage.
This is interesting.
So then there's this backstage
conversation, Rosenberg. Basically,
as soon as he gets off stage,
his boss, my boss comes out,
pokes his head around
the curtain and goes,
did you say something about Nicki
Minaj? I was like, ah. And I,
I legit didn't remember.
I'm like, Oh yeah, I did.
And he's like, yeah, well she just
canceled the show so she's not coming.
And I was like, I was like, oh.
And I looked at my phone and I go
to Twitter sitting on the stage,
the crowd's all out there.
I'm at giant stadium and I look on
Twitter and I go to trends and on the main
trend page it just says Peter
Rosenberg and I was like,
oh wow, this is nuts.
It is a Sunday afternoon
at like five o'clock.
And I was like the third
most trending right,
being in the world [inaudible]
I was just watching my name
get bigger in a moment.
97 CJ, Peter Rosenberg, one of the
big dramas that happen in New York.
I was reading just my name
over and over and over again.
The dual roles and Vernon dual
from high 37 Peter Rosenberg.
All these people saying, I
don't know who this guy is,
but he's dissing my favorite artists.
I'm just really disappointed and I
don't understand how she, I was reading,
who is this guy? What he said, starship
songs not hitting out here Rosenberg.
Man That's not real hip hop.
He was the one man say one thing and
everybody stopped was four then he must've
gotten some serious
credit from this. He, yes.
Not only was his name getting out there,
but it was getting out there as I'm
the gatekeeper. I'm the defender.
I'm the defender of the real,
the realness.
I couldn't appreciate it at first because
I didn't know if I was maybe going to
get fired for messing up summer jam
because Nikki's ain't beefing with the
station. Yeah, come on. Your state
will even say something to my,
she's calling in, you know,
mad at the station of apologizing.
Nikki Busta rhymes gets involved trying
to broker a deal on master flex gets
involved, change some emails.
They're trying to reach a day time now
it becomes a month long process. That's
nuts. If they say unanimously, no,
you were wrong about that song.
This is our song. We included
in our map of what's going on.
Stop trying to draw the map. What do
you say to that in your inside of you?
I think my gut reaction
is you know nothing.
You don't draw the map,
you need people like us to draw the map
or there's nothing or what is there if
if we don't get to determine
certain things, who, who does,
we should leave that to the crazy 13 year
olds who may not even like this artist
and two years as well
woman hearing that. It's to Kelly again,
this idea that young girls
will hear starships and say,
oh that's hip hop. That's
what I want to hear.
That's what I'm going to judge everything
against is wildly unfair to the
intelligence of young girls.
Freddie says they can figure out the
difference between hip hop and pop.
They don't need help. It's
insulting. And furthermore,
when he chose starships to single out,
it felt revealing of another layer to
this debate that people weren't saying out
loud, which is when people refer
to things as quote real hip hop,
that's usually code for aggressive
street, masculine, authentic.
Whereas when they say pop,
that's usually code for feminine,
which is a perversion of the music
period. And so there is this idea that,
you know, people make
songs for the ladies,
which implies that all the rest of them
are songs that we can't hear or God
forbid understand.
Okay.
So all of this was swirling around
months go by and then fast forward to the
week before the next summer jam.
This is 2014, 2013 in 2013. Yeah,
the food is still going at this point.
It's a year later. But going to Andrew,
Nikki decides it's time to settle,
maybe because she wanted to perform
it that year. Summer jam or so.
Nicki Minaj sits down with radio station
hot 97 to clear the air with DJ Peter
Rosenberg. She comes to the station
summer jam to make her peace and they do
this whole interview with Rosenberg and
Nicki Minaj and Ebro the
boss is moderating on the
air on the air. Rosenberg.
So this is all you sir. Um, where
would you like this interview to go?
[inaudible]
um, I dunno, I'm excited. I'm
excited to see Nikki because uh,
it's very odd to have someone
that you don't know very well,
who's become like such a fixture in
your life. Like I've always wondered,
I was always like,
I wonder if Nikki knows that she's come
up every day in my life for 350 days,
like point that where starships got
played on my wedding and it was like the
biggest deal at my wedding was starships
playing at my wedding after some
opening remarks, Peter
basically apologizes.
I am sorry that things
went as left as they did.
I never had ill feelings about you
as a human being ever basically says,
I have nothing against you as a person
beyond my sort of distaste for that song.
That's cool. It's one onto the
branch. Do you mean that? Yeah,
I mean she then goes out of her way to
apologize to her fans for skipping out on
the Gig. But um, then the
gloves come off. You know what?
Like I get it. Like that's
what you do, I guess. To me,
I just don't know your resume.
You know what I'm saying?
So I never found you funny. I
never found you entertaining.
I never found you smart.
I just found you annoying because
you know I grew up in New York.
I've grown up on hot 97 like I know Angie
and I know flex and Mr c and all these
people, whether they like me
or whether or not we get along,
I just know their resume. But
like with you, I was just like,
who are you [inaudible]
I don't recognize you as an
authority on what's authentic
to me. You don't have enough of
a resume to make those comments.
Who are you to tell me what to do?
What people don't understand is that
when I came, when I was doing this,
I took a lot from people from men.
She was like my whole career,
they've just been random men who have
like been in a position to stop me and
tell me why I'm not good enough.
I just did. I just don't want
a lot of stuff from guys.
And here you are. I don't know
you. You're just some random man.
And then Ebro jumps in and
kind of jokingly trying to
lighten the mood goes and
you white. I didn't even say that.
I never should ever implied
anything about white.
She plugged them and then she jumps
in and goes, no, no, no. That too.
Being white also struck a chord with me
if I'm being honest, because I was like,
Yo, he's on a black station
dissing black people. Like I don't,
I don't. I just didn't
like the feel of it.
Did you get back to that idea,
that category idea that like when you
don't have that like set list of criteria
to help you figure out
who's in and who's out.
It's all about a gut feeling into Nicki
Minaj that moment have a white guy from
the suburbs tell her a black woman from
Queens that she's not hip hop enough.
[inaudible]
just felt wrong. But then Ali Shahi
Muhammad from tribe called quest,
put it this way, maybe it feels wrong,
but maybe this is actually evolution.
40 years into it, that's
what it's supposed to be.
At some point we're all going to be so
far removed from the origin that no one
would then qualify really.
But if you're going to be the
person to carry the torch,
I guess so be the gatekeeper and
at some point what qualifies you?
It's your heart miss that feeling.
You could be Bill Gates kid is still
understand the struggle enough to be like,
Yo, I'm riding with that. Yeah
and I want to fight for that.
I was like, Yo, he's on a black
station. Distinct black people.
Like I don't, I don't, I just
didn't like the feel of it.
Who am I going to dis if not black
people. I'm on a hip hop station.
I have to just blind people
sometimes I if I just wipe up slowly.
Now you watch your mouth, sir. You
only want me to go with Mac Miller.
I mean who am I going to do Macklemore's
am actually plenty of artists now.
I used to only just white rappers,
but as I've gotten further along,
I felt I earned the right to
dis all things I didn't like.
I was like, no, we
can wait.
Rosenberg to this day takes credit for
her summer jam saying my next project is
going to be a US hardcore hip hop
album. When her album's awesome,
you will see me take lots of
credit for it. Absolutely.
She called me the other day and
I was half asleep and she's like,
hello, I know you're thinking,
why is this bitch calling me?
And I was like not at all what's going on?
And she wanted to ask me about her new
song and the amazing thing was she wanted
to ask me an opinion on something and it
makes me feel ultimately super special.
So we s Peter Legs. So what does that
mean? Like if you are now a gatekeeper,
you white guy from suburban Maryland.
I am very commercial radio station.
What does that mean for hip hop?
Does that mean that hip hop
has by default been co-opted?
Cause like here you are. I don't know.
I mean I feel like hip hop is in a better
place now than before I started doing
this. I would break it
down on paper and go,
let me tell you where we were when I
started my underground show in 2007.
And let me tell you where I think we are
in 2014 and let me show you how many of
those artists I broke in support it and
worked hard with and talked to the label
about and pushed and how many
I had an involvement with.
I think you'd see a really
high percentage. So that
was part of his answer.
We asked Andrew the same question.
It's complicated. I mean, I, look, I,
I don't think that hip hop is
dead. There was some quote, um,
Frank Zappa I think said jazz
isn't dead. It just smells funny.
Like, I don't think hip
hop is wonderful. Yeah.
I mean, that's should be our title
up. Isn't that funny? But I do think,
I think hip hop isn't
dead. It just smells funny.
It would always smells a little funky.
[inaudible]
huge thanks to Andrew Moranz, uh,
and the New Yorker magazine for
letting us borrow Andrew for a beat.
Definitely check out his story
in, uh, The New Yorker magazine.
It's called an old school.
It's a great story.
It goes into way more detail
than we can get into here. Also,
big thanks to Frannie Kelly
and Alicia, Ede Muhammad, uh,
who together they cohost the NPR podcast.
Microphone check and a well, I'm
Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thank you for listening. Oh, and
before we go, just one last thing.
So lest you think that like hip
hop has arrived at this new, um,
like quote, post racial
situation, which, you know,
we for a second we were like, maybe
we're just thinking out loud with Peter.
He was like, no way. No. Got It.
If there's one thing I could
demand that air during this piece,
it would be this statement right here.
Nothing has driven me more crazy over
the course of my time in hip hop than
white people who come up
to me and go, you know,
and it used to be really bad
when he first came out. You know,
m and m is just so talented. I
don't even listen to hip hop,
but M&M I mean, now he's good. Well,
if you don't listen to hip hop,
why the hell should I care?
What your thoughts on m and m are and
how do you know that he's good? No,
you know that he's white. You know
that he's white and is M&M Good?
Yes. It just so happens that he's as
good as you as you're guessing he is.
But that's random. You don't even
know that m and m could be any,
could've been one of the dudes for Milli
Vanilli and you would've thought it was
great and that drives me nuts.
And so anytime I think about, oh,
we're post racial,
just look at what m and m concerts
look like and what the sales look like.
And you can be instantly reminded that
even though m and m has no experience
that average suburban white America could
ever identify with, I mean culturally,
the experience he went through is much
more common with someone who went with,
went through a black struggle than any
sort of regular white suburban life.
And this is the guy who came up in a
rough situation in a million ways, um,
was the odd man out all the time,
never had anything, and then makes it,
and all of a sudden the fact that
people like, oh, I so identify with him.
What is it? Why do I identify with
a guy who's from a trailer park?
I'm from a history of drug abuse,
who raps about things that I'd be
terrified of if a black man was saying it.
But I identify with him so much.
And then m and m cause he's
amazing raps about this same thing.
He does a song called Dear White
America. Ray tells them, you're an idiot.
You let your kids listen to me,
but you wouldn't let them listen to
anyone else just because I'm white.
You're an idiot. And they love
it. It's unbelievable. Okay.